cinéma toujours avec la sortie mercredi
dans les salles de rien sur robert
réalisé par pascal bonitzer avec
sandrine kiberlain et fabrice luchini
que j'ai plaisir de recevoir sur ce
plateau
une comédie de moeurs au ton plutôt
décalé très belle performance des
acteurs et des dialogues ciselés parce
qu'elle défend jean louis ousset gaulois
les gauloises blondes super lie la fin
des gauloises en super légers même s'il
est un peu parano dans la vie de didier
en apparence tout va bien un travail de
journaliste dans une revue prestigieuse
une copine dont il est follement
amoureux mais ça ne va pas durer
parce qu'il a écrit un article sur un
film qu'il n'a pas vu sa vie bascule
de toute façon tu as eu tort en écrit
pas sans avoir vu je n'avais pas le
choix il y avait urgence
on a toujours le choix voilà pour le
point de départ est l'argument d'un film
tout à la fois grave et jubilatoire moi
je suis pas d'essayer c'est juste un
hématome pas pouvoir tellement menées çà
ne s'en relève pas moins sa trésorerie
on va pouvoir se résorber on laisse
tomber
tong là semble que refuse d'ailleurs le
titre choisi par pascal bonitzer s'est
passé chez cerné par les rovers
je suis cernée par les robert parce que
j'étais bien inviter chez vous ce soir
ce mélange d'absurde et de gravité
culmine dans la saisine ou didier se
fait littéralement lynché par un
parterre d'intellectuels qui lui
reprochent sa désinvolture votre petit
style cache une fosse à vide profond
quand j'ai su vous n'aviez pas hésité à
attaquer une oeuvre que vous n'avez même
pas vu je parle de ce film bosniaque le
nom certes vous savez tous ici de quoi
je parle j'ai appuyé samedi j'étais
horrifiée j'ai pas voulu quoi cette
scène on a une espèce de
il ya une dimension de cauchemar qui
peut être
sous l'angle comique pu être vue sous
l'angle pas dans le dos et
et j'espère que ces deux extraits la
semaine tous les deux ça fonctionne et
c'est justement ce qui fait
l'originalité de rien sur robert
vous pouvez me croire ce film là moi je
les ai vus